it's so fun you get so drunk you start a
bonfire outside you a fire bomb
anybody that tries to get through the
gates love time it's your cousin you
know you don't even care
[Music]
just illustrating xxx
I'm gonna talk about some jobs I had I
had a great job I worked at a beep Aggie
plat for three years anybody else does
that the whore Bellamy Peggy platter
double Iowa by the way if you work on
the kill floor of be Peggy Platte you
will get very drunk every day okay
there's a documentary called America
dream of one Academy Award at 1990 about
our meet Peggy plant I voted for every
strike that came up I didn't even read
the paperwork you know hey by the way
man it's so fun you get so drunk you
start a bonfire outside you
firebomb anybody that tries to get
through the gates a lot of times it's
your cousin you know you don't even care
and then people are were interviewing
and sometimes they're like why are you
striking I go I have no idea but it's
fun man I know that and if you
watched a documentary you see what
happens so the company just fired us and
just changed the name of the business
and then they hired people from other
countries to work for half the play yeah
anyway it did work out too well but uh
my best job I think was McDonald's so
after that I went to the University of
Iowa and I needed money right so
personally I applied at Pizza Hut but
they made you take a lie detector and
then they ask you questions you know
real person was like have you ever
stolen food and what earlier my life I
worked on a farm I grew up on farms and
I was Bailey Hafer guy we all did for
$40 and this guy was supposed to pay a
dollar forty-eight hour and he's an
asshole and he only gave us 70 cents an
hour because he said we drank too much
water so I sold one of his cows
anyway that's some tangley ceiling I
think he's technically invited for real
I know there's helium anyway so uh and I
had like a Pinto it was a tough
anyway but I had those budgie core I
mean he was safe anyway it's log sorry
that's true so I get this job at Epic
donaldson Iowa City and it is the best
job because if you unload the truck on
Thursdays you get one meal of whatever
you want to eat so I would have ate a
Big Macs with quarter pounder beet and a
diet coke and then I would start my
workday you know feeling totally sick
and disgusting and that's it's shocky I
became a drug addict because of that
anyway but I love there I got to be to
play right at the Ronald McDonald for
the kids on Sundays with terrible
hangovers it was just a wonderful place
to work and all my friends loved it you
know how your friends love it when you
work in a place like that right they
line up there and they want free
food you know and it's really hard
because they got computers so you got to
pay attention and keep track of the food
and you have to pretend you throw food
into the hopper that was in there too
long and you've thrown it away so when
you're giving away free food and you
know Ed's ed by the way all that food
that was in the hopper that they put it
into a trash thing I take home every
night and my roommates we'd love it and
sometimes we get a bad fillet of fish or
something somebody gets really sick but
anyway then otherwise it's a waste it's
only been there 12 hours that's fine
so anyway
so my buddy mo who's still my buddy
I you know he comes in every Friday and
he wants a bag of cheeseburgers so I
give up a bag a cheeseburger give all my
friends whatever and then I had to
figure out on the computer you know cuz
it makes real smart work in there and
and then I see mo he's talking to the
owner Kevin and they're pointing at me
and I'm like what's going on and he goes
this customer says you forgot some of
his cheeseburgers like my old
buddy is narky on me who I just gave
free you know that's that's the kind of
friends I have so that's not a party
night job at pulse discount that this
really helped and what I did the pulse
discount was every day I'd go into work
and then I get a gym bag off the shelf
and I'd fill it up with stuff that
friends wanted me to steal and and I go
home with a full gym bag and the owner
would take me home and every night it
was scary cuz it still had the things on
it and you know the clips
just prayed he'd shut off the security
system as I walked by the cash registers
and so it's a very safe place to work
and then and then one day a beer
distributor came in and said he wanted
it's about some golf clubs or stuff and
I said I'll make you a deal you drop off
50 cases of beer at my house and I'll
make this trade so what we came up you
know a good deal for everybody and it
was a Friday night Iowa football game so
I knew we were gonna be partying very
hard and also McDonald's we had this
game going
and every time you bought a bag of food
we put a game to get in and you could
win a big neck or a big breakfast or
five dollars and so let's get ready to
leave it's Friday night and I see a box
of those 6001 like that I'm taking
at home so I take home the box and me my
firm it stayed up all night our figured
elves were we're just destroyed because
you got to rip the sides up and in the
morning we had 157 three big references
and weeded up all night with the free
beer and there's like a real classy
party like you know approach or
something so anyway we go down to the
girls so as I worked there I can't cash
it in but my buddy Bo can so I parked
behind the dumpster and Moe goes in and
he goes up to the front and he put put
till about there and he says I'd like a
hundred fifty seven free big references
and then the lady goes oh I'm sorry sir
did you not read the fine print it's
only one per visit and my friend Bowie
is pretty smart he's like boy the kids
at the home are gonna be pretty sad and
Kevin the owner who still the owner runs
over and goes sir
we will honor those for the kids so the
next thing I see is my buddy Bo with a
giant cardboard box full of big
breakfast I'm like holy we did it
we did it
brilliant and then right behind him is
capable the owner of the Gulf's with
another big box of big breakfast and I
realized I'm going to be fired in about
five seconds and Kevin that guy he's
such a jerk he didn't take the food back
he just looked at me in the car and just
gave me that I I'm so disappointed
I considered you assistant manager
material Tama
you could have ended up at hamburger you
anyway so that's my last steak at
McDonald's so later in life at Oh sad it
was a great job later in life I got
sober I went to get sober yet though you
list with all the people you need to
make a beds to and mind was a pretty
extensive list and let's I guess the
girlfriend says credited I'd Road I got
to McDonald's and Paul's desktop and I
said the text and I called Kevin and
he's such a nice guy he cried and he
would have take the money he had to give
it to the Ronald McDonald House how nice
is that
right cuz I stolen you know ten thousand
dollars worth of food I'm as pretty that
is the one thing they did do when I left
they stopped putting pockets on the
uniforms because I zero anyway
but there's a happy ending because what
time I host the Saturday Night Live and
I got to play a McDonald's manager and
is when Bill Clinton was president and
would always go to McDonald's at the
great Phil Hartman who I love to yeah
everybody knows the people that I love
are dad now I have apparently but a Phil
Hartman was wonderful
and I had I played had his name tag out
there as a tribute to that guy so that's
a happy ending to that story thank you
guys very much